dv terre est une société viennoise qui
est l'une des pionnières en ce qui
concerne les simulateurs de conduite le
but apprendre à des professionnels ou
non à réduire leur temps de réaction
face à une situation difficile mais je
vais rouler beaucoup plus près du
véhicule qui est devant et vous verrez à
ce moment-là mieux la distance de
sécurité qui est laissée pas à le cours
du thar le sénateur s'est déjà de
permettre aux conducteurs de vivre à peu
près toutes les situations qu'il pourra
un jour ou l'autre
rencontrés sur la route puisque le
sénateur c'est un outil qui est très
souple il permet de conduire en ville
sur route sur autoroute de jour de nuit
sous la pluie par temps de brouillard et
il va permettre également de réaliser
des exercices techniques apprendre à
freiner d'urgence et s'est passé pas
idée aujourd'hui toutes les voitures
sont équipées de la déesse antiblocage
de roues
c'est relativement simple de freiner à
100% d'efficacité mais ça ça provis pas
et la société propose tout type de
formation pour les voitures les vélos ou
encore les bus et le simulateur séduit
les professionnels de la conduite
les gens sont satisfaits puisque ben il
renouvelle d'année en année les
formations et puis ben comme monsieur de
même terre si vous voulez remet à chaque
fois des nouveaux scénarios tout ça ben
c'est toujours enrichissant de
travailler avec nous parce que là on
n'arrête pas de progresser car pour
l'heure tout le temps et donc si on
progresse les entreprises progressent
etc
et c'est pour ça qu'on a fidélisé pas
mal de l'entreprise quoi avec deux
millions de chiffre d'affaires des
belles terres vise aujourd'hui
l'international
elle a déjà exporté plusieurs de ses
simulateurs à l'étranger